c'est au moment de la coupe du monde
2010 que l' affaire avait éclaté
plusieurs joueurs de l'équipe de france
dont franck ribéry et karim benzema
avait été impliqué dans le scandale de
la ferraille a une histoire de
prostitution qui avait à l'époque
défrayé la chronique
mais aujourd'hui près de 10 ans après
son scandale très médiatique une
nouvelle témoin vient de relancer la
faire pour elsa ya n'a pas agi seul et
aurait été la maîtresse du marchand
d'art guy bouvier qui est accusé par cet
ex escort-girl d'être à l'origine de ce
système de proxénétisme
la jeune femme qui se fait appeler sarah
aurait rencontré zahia à l'été 2009 lors
de dîners libertin pour lesquelles les
filles auraient été payées 2000 euros en
liquide de la main d'yves bouvier si ces
accusations avaient déjà fait l'objet
d'articles en 2015 et de la part de
titres de presse qui vous via vais
attaquer en justice et pour lesquels il
avait remporté les procès pour
diffamation aujourd'hui les confidences
de la jeune femme vont plus loin
sarah déclare avoir été contrainte par
yves bouvier de rester à son hôtel alors
qu'elle souhaitait témoigner contre lui
elle déclare également avoir été poussé
par l'homme d'affaires à faire chanter
un agent du fisc suisse pour éviter aux
marchands d'art un contrôle fiscal
des confidences qui pourrait relancer le
procès autour de l'affairé zahia à
l'heure où l'avocat d'abou sofiane
ancien candidat de la nouvelle star
condamnée en 2015 pour proxénétisme
aggravé dépose une demande d'acte
préalable à une requête en révision de
la faire ce soir abou sofiane est avec
nous pour tout nous dire sur cette
affaire merci à vous d'être avec ma mère
merci merci d'être là alors vous avez
été condamné pour proxénétisme aggravé
suite au scandale zahia qui a secoué le
monde du football en 2010 alors c'est
grâce aux témoignages inédits d'une
escort girl
kabou sofiane d espérer obtenir la
révision du procès puisque sarah une
escort girl âgée de 49 ans a déclaré que
c'est l'homme d'affaires suisse yves
bouvier qui aurait été à l'origine des
relations sexuelles tarifées de zahia et
pas vous alors c'est du ce copain avec
zahia en fait lors non en fait oui bien
sûr c'était mon ami déjà d'une part mais
ce témoignage pour moi est très
important c'est reed parce que ça fait
dix ans que j'attends ce moment là j'ai
toujours clamé mon innocence parce que
mon seul ma seule erreur aujourd'hui
c'était enfin à l'époque c'était d'être
l'ami de zahia d'organiser des soirées
qu'elle venait mais soir comme tout le
monde continuera les soirées parce qu'on
veut savoir d'âge organisé les soirées
dans les boîtes que tout le monde
connaît sur les champs-elysées donc
c'est pas des soirées intimes prises
aurélie d'habitude non non non non
c'était justement on en reviendra sur
pour mon dire se montra libertines non
ces soirées que des boîtes de nuit très
connue des champs-elysées et comment ça
se passe partout tu viens bah tiens ta
copine elle est mignonne
à la table bonjour après comme j'ai
toujours dit assayas est pas ma soeur
c'est pas ma femme elle fait ce qu'elle
veut après salon d'hiver acquis qu'elle
veut maintenant aujourd'hui je suis
vraiment heureux parce que j'ai reçu un
coup de fil il ya quelques jours et
c'était pour moi j'habite à marrakech
maintenant donc on m'appelle je me
réveille à 9 heures du matin je reçois
pas le message on me dit oui voilà il ya
quelque chose qui se passe c'est un
nouveau témoignage qui eux qui me
dédouane totalement puisque en fait à
l'époque on m'a accusé d'être le
proxénète de zahia à une période où je
n'avais pas vu ça hier c'est à dire que
les monts les faits ont éclaté en avril
2010 et moi j'ai toujours dit que je
voyage je n'avais j'avais pas de contact
avec m
depuis un an sert depuis le printemps
2009 paraît que ça
si vous avez tout perdu suite à cette
affaire ben j'ai perdu et c'est simple
j'ai perdu mon travail d'ailleurs à
l'époque j'étais un petit animateur de
télé j'avais je venais de sortir un film
j'ai perdu aussi je devais me marier
l'été 2010 j'ai perdu ma future femme
peut-être la mère de mes enfants
aujourd'hui je sais pas j'ai perdu si
l'essentiel de mes rêves j'ai perdu mes
liens familiaux j'ai perdu beaucoup de
choses donc on vous a accusé d'être le
proxénète de zahia mais rien ne m'est
rien à voir vous n'avez jamais fait de
voilà de proxénétisme pas du tout où
cyril à l'époque j'étais animateur télé
mais j'étais j'avais vous avez été
condamné pour ça j'ai été condamné et
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je suis
très content parce que le témoignage de
cette de ces demoiselles que je connais
pas d'ailleurs et je l'en remercie c'est
que elle elle donne des faits elle donne
des preuves des vidéos donnent des
photos à dun ddd adresse à donne des
noms de gens très connus parce qu'il y
avait réellement réseau et surtout c'est
comme un verrou prochain à l'époque de
du printemps 2009 à printemps 2010
d'être le prochain procès de zahia alors
que je n'avais jamais vu d'ailleurs
j'étais sur écoute moi même pendant six
à huit mois
il ya hawking aucune conversation quand
vous avez été condamné alors justement
alors c'est pour ça que cette affaire
c'était vraiment un fiasco juridique
pourquoi parce que au moment des faits
d'ailleurs on accuser à tort deux
joueurs de foot franck ribéry et karim
benzema karim
d'où le fiasco ils ont été relaxés pour
la simple et bonne raison que karim
benzema a toujours nié les faits et
d'ailleurs on a eu la preuve que au
final il n'a jamais couché avec elle
elle a menti franck ribéry effectivement
avoué mehal a toujours menti sur son âge
alors ce qui est très important
justement sur ce dossier là c'est que
l'escort girl qui a témoigné donne des
des adresses et surtout des voyages des
voyages très précis entre printemps 2009
et printemps 2010 où son compagnon sans
citer son nom lui-même avait pris les
billets d'avion donc il savait
pertinemment l'âge de zahia alors que
tout le monde ne saute à la menti à tout
le monde sauf sauf à lui qui était qui
était au courant d'accord excusez moi
j'en perds mes mots vous connaissez pas
ce que vous êtes à la nonciature mandat
par contre d'un procès verbaux le dit
hein
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
franck ribéry a été totalement mis hors
de cause mais ya que des joueurs de foot
ont été touchés mais justement c'est ça
qui me dérange c'est qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui tout le monde parle de deux
joueurs alors qu'il ya moult personnes
qui ont été impliquées dans cette dans
cette affaire gens connus des mets très
connue des il ya des animateurs télé ya
des chanteurs 16e et à politis et 8 non
non il ya un animal c'est des gens des
animaux de l'amitié un animateur connu
kaka vent en poupe que dans une chaîne
concurrente
oui oui à une seule concurrente on va
dire que gardienne persiennes bien sûr
ah oui aoudia le profil du redire landry
d el haddaoui ah bah alors on va vous a
pas dit non mais c'est quand même une
grosse révélation il ya il ya d'autres
il ya d'autres gens bien sûr il y avait
déjà des québécois yann et maurice aussi
très très connu du grand public non
merde qui paradoxalement j'ai envie de
dire sérine qui n'est pas forcément à la
base attiré par les femmes mais qui
à profiter de ces affaires on est tous
comme ça on va se retrouver dans un
c'est vrai que la ferraille a rebondi
alors on va rappeler les faits la
ferraille à la ferraille à 4 en 2010 à
quelques mois de la coupe du monde en
afrique du sud
ça fait un énorme scandale puisque des
joueurs de l'équipe de france sont
censées être impliqué dedans ses joueurs
ont eu recours à des services d'escort
girls
alors qu'elle était meilleure mineurs 7
c'est cette escorte girl avait menti à
tout le monde sait ce que vous vous
disiez puisque c'est vrai que voilà elle
a dit à tout le monde qualités majeures
mais en fait elle était mineure depuis
c'est vrai que ça ya fait une énorme
carrière
mine de rien mais c'est surtout que
zahia pour moi en tout cas lorsque je
les connais je connais dans un club très
occupé de paris non déjà théoriquement
sur les champs elysées que d'être
inconnu à l'arc de triomphe est
physiquement là on la voit mais moi je
les ai connus vraiment à l'époque
ouais bien sûr elle faisait pas 30 ans
mais faisait pas 16 et 17 ans à l'aller
saint rolan en 2010 on est assez habile
et toujours en talons très sexy oui mais
bon 18 19 ans faire attention quand même
alors en 2013 devant les caméras de 7 à
8 zahia est revenu sur le scandale qui
l'a fait connaître pour elle ça a été un
véritable choc et pourtant après mine de
rien ça la salle a propulsé avec vous
non salariés s'associent sanaa mais
regardez le jour sécréter qu'on vous
avez réagi
je ne sais pas comment vous l'expliquez
mais c'était un choc mais un énorme choc
c'était qu'est ce que je vais devenir
mon dieu est-ce que ce qui était surtout
dur pourquoi est ce que je subis une
telle humiliation mais qu'est ce que
j'ai fait j'étais effondrée
j'ai 18 ans ma vie commence et je suis
catholique et où l'inter est partout je
vais aller on va me reconnaître on va
dire c'est elle et c'était cela la je ne
préfère ne pas je ne veux pas dire et
c'est ça qui était dur alors que faire
mais je suis prisonnière de sa sé sak i
o rim
c'était je n'ai plus de vie alors la
ferraille a rebondi aujourd'hui avec les
des nouveaux témoignages
et c'est vrai qu'elle donc c'était elle
était venue escort girl et vous dites
donc
zahia mine de rien c'est vrai que les
deux joueurs de foot qui ont été touchés
c'est et karim benzema qui a brillé on a
vu car il n'avait rien à voir dans
l'histoire et franck ribéry voilà il lui
et pas du tout au courant qu'elle était
mineure et séries que vous dites il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'autres gens c'est
eux qui ont été ciblés parce qu'on était
lors de la coupe du monde et que c'est
vrai que les joueurs de foot était
vraiment ciblé à ce moment là et vous
dites qu'il ya plein d'autres gens qui
ont été donc touché par la feria
je sais que gilles et je vous lis gilles
mahé fait des révélations il ya de ça
trois quatre on est apparemment vous
avez les mêmes infos tous les deux jl-c
va être sans citer de noms mais je
citerai pas non mais oui je vous avais
dit parce qu'en fait j'ai 20 ans j'ai
écrit un livre sur l'affairé zahia et
servait je peux pas dire que j'avais
consulté les documents de justice mais
j'avais consulté des documents où il y
avait des noms donc effectivement des
footballeurs un prestigieux animateurs
des journalistes j'en ai mais les deux
secteurs très connu oui il n'a jamais
été qui n'a jamais été inquiété
d'ailleurs juste et rebondir série
dallas sur la vidéo je vois qu'alain que
depuis que je la connais elle a quand
même appris à parler français
parce qu'avant c'était une catastrophe
vous ne voyez plus du tout ah mais alors
je vais une petite anecdote qui date
juste 2 il ya deux mois c'est simple sur
instagram
je la suis pas ce que c'est normal c'est
pour moi c'est je peux pas dire que
c'est un peu une frustration parce
qu'aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que je reprends ses
assaillants parce que sur les
procès-verbaux m'enfonce pas au
contraire mais ce que je reproche c'est
son silence parce que elle est partie
sur les plateaux télé pour faire la
promotion de ses petites culottes tout
ça mais par contre moi j'aurais aimé que
face à face caméra a dit quoi ce qu'elle
a dit exactement à la donner une seule
et unique interview c'est dans paris
match a dit je n'ai pas de souteneur
abou est un ami et je fais la prostituée
tout seul donc comment aujourd'hui on
peut aujourd'hui parce que moi ça fait
10 ans cyril aujourd'hui même si les
gens j'ai refait ma vie mais à des gens
quand ils voyaient disent oui et puis
dès qu'ils se retournent disent quoi
amélie c'était la macaza ya bien sûr et
donc moi qui suis issue d'une petite
famille de banlieue de lyon de culture
marocaine de confession musulmane
je les parents qui sont mieux donc pour
nous c'est tabou que j'aurais préféré
qu'on m'accuse de braqueurs de dinner
mais proxénète chez nous c'est très fin
un de rien du tout même convaincu des
noms mais aujourd'hui encore donc pour
moi c'est important ce témoignage de
cette fille parce que ce témoignage est
très très d'ailleurs je vous dis
clairement et officiellement ça va faire
un bon parce qu'il ya vraiment des
éléments à charge contre son compagnon
il va avoir des noms qui vont sortir
ah non mais énormément de gens connus ah
oui très connue très connu à tort qu a
dit non
pas sans citer non sans citer mme lam et
déjà déjà il ya des animateurs il ya un
animateur très connu il ya très connue
d'une chaîne hertzienne which he hnr
yens comme jeudi qui est le profil de
gendre idéal
d'accord il ya un chanteur très connu
bon lui qui a déjà eu des démêlés avec
la justice mais bon façon chanteur très
connu aux idées années 80 il ya eu un
ami est revenue on sait qu'un celle des
années 80 bien moi non mais ironiquement
un rappeur qu'il ya eu
à faire enfin quand je dis un ami c'est
assez ironique ya eu ou non il ya un
chanteur d'ailleurs que c'est sorti dans
la presse qui est très connu un
américain ça on peut le dire parce que
c'est sorti dans la presse et ne-yo qui
quand même qui est sortie qui était
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas si à l'époque
il était dans les procès verbaux et les
venue à paris alors il a été entendu
mais l'a jamais été inquiétés j'ai pas
vu les procès verbaux peux pas le dire
mais oui je me sens dans circuler je
vous dis c'est vrai que tout ce que dit
bien sûr à bout ça n'engage que lui nous
on n'est pas du tout au courant de la
faire abou sofiane voilà il a écrasé sa
yam a tué vous dites donc ça va vraiment
rebondir qui va y avoir d'énormes noms
qui vont sortir et c'est vrai que ça
fait peur voilà à tout tu sais que dans
le voilà dans le milieu cette affaire
est un fait peur voilà parce qu'on a
peur qu'ils aient d'autres noms qui se
retrouver si ces noms sortent en quoi ça
vous aide en face à cela la balle à moi
c'est pas les noms aujourd'hui en france
or une chose c'est comment aujourd'hui
je suis l'avion alors moi les noms je
les ai depuis dix ans si j'avais voulu
faire le buzz chez pas là je vous
explique cette simple clair net et
précis et moi j'ai refait ma vie à
marrakech je suis bien moi aujourd'hui
je suis pas là pour faire du buzz ou de
chercher de l'argent je cherche juste à
rétablir l'honneur de mon honneur et
l'honneur de ma famille c'est tout ce
que je demande et aujourd'hui cette
jeune fille que je ne connais pas qui a
fait cette déclaration et qui vraiment
très importante parce que j'ai accès
mois au dossier parce que c'est moi qui
ai demandé à inscrire une roquette de
fait c'est accablant
c'est accablant parce que là il ya un
vrai réseau et le réseau je suis moi
même si choqué à bout à bout juste je
vais juste vous dire un truc parce que
les personnes notent que vous ciblez
mais il y aura peut-être elle aussi elle
ne savait pas tout comme voilà les
laiteries ne savait pas qu'elle était
mineure on va revenir garde non mais je
peux dire et je peux répondre si oui
elle ne savait pas la wii tout alors le
cheveu répond tout de suite et ce n'est
pas des charges de ces gens là voilà
tout le monde n'était personne n'était
au courant les seules personnes qui est
au courant que zahia était mineure et
qui se prostituaient c'est sa mère parce
qu'elle pouvait pas ignorer que sa fille
était mineure
elle rentrait tous les soirs et celle
qui finançait tout la maison parce que
j'ai quand même côtoyé ses filles à un
moment donné de ma vie et ce compagnon
qui avec preuves à l'appui aujourd'hui
je parle avec des vrais éléments que
clermont avocats avec des billets
d'avion il ya eu même des voyages en
corse parce qu'il a un bien là bas un
bateau il ya eu beaucoup de choses des
voyages à dubaï quand est mineur tu
voyages pas dubaï
il ya elle s'était confiée sur son
parcours et sur les raisons pour
lesquelles elle était devenue escort
girl alors qu'elle était mineure zahia
regarder les hyper consciente à l'époque
une mineure n'a pas droit de faire ça
non non ce n'est pas ça je pensais pas
ce genre de choses parce que c'était le
moyen le plus simple de gagner sa vie on
a tous des parties savez on a dû faire
quelque chose pour pouvoir s'en sortir
ou gagner d'avéo avancer et pour moi
c'était tout simplement un étape de ma
vie et après je ne sais pas pourquoi
j'ai choisi ça mais c'est tout
simplement parce que nous a fait des
propositions tout simplement oui voilà
donc c'est vrai que la ferraille a
rebondi aujourd'hui vous ce que vous
voulez c'est rétablir la vérité
zahia m'a tuer mon combat pour la vérité
il ya ya ya juste il ya un tweet de
benjamin griveaux qui dit je n'ai rien à
voir là dedans attention si pascal
beaucoup de jeunes qui regardent
l'émission
il faut voir que malaga pc ya d'autres
moyens que de gagner sa vie quand
j'allais rebondir sur la médaille a dit
que c'est une facilité pour elle de
gagner l'argent que tu dois être en plus
c'est devenu une énorme star vous allez
jaja les rebonds j'allais justement d'y
revenir culture passage à dire
franchement aujourd'hui juste j'en veux
un peu à certains médias parce que zahia
est passé du trottoir au podium
moi à l'époque j'étais encore j'avais le
vent en poupe et ge aujourd'hui j'ai
tout perdu mais c'est pas grave il ya un
dieu il est grand et juste une chose
c'est que finalement il n'y a pas de
morale dans cette histoire parce que
comme le dit géraldine pour les jeunes
filles qui nous regardent et bat
aujourd'hui en fait indirectement en
train de faire comprendre aux jeunes
filles pour réussir ma faut faire là non
mais elle a droit à une deuxième chance
pour autant louis la met juste à bout il
ya plein de gens là sur retour ailleurs
fait réseaux sociaux saragih de partout
sur les voilà les noms vous avez balancé
sachiez palais dont il n'a pas balancé
de leur passage et donc vous ne dites
donc il y aura des as 10 à 10 animateurs
il ya des rails des chanteurs il ya
voilà il ya plein de gens connus il ya
du journal journalistes seraient même
des politiques
il ya même des politiques une sur quatre
pattes soffer livreur
[Rires]
elle est à bout quand vous nous dites
politiques c'est les politiques qui sont
encore eux étaient en activité
essentiellement entre 2007 et 2012
d'accord donc dépôt des ministres une
députée ministre ministre non député oui
très connu oui surtout un même
conseiller d'un ancien président à oui
voilà contrat entre 2007 et 2012 s'il va
vite possible et 1 voix la bombe à lui
nous a foutu dans la merde
bien sûr aux gages cadets voilà mais la
buba veuve voilà on va avoir à suivre
cette affaire puisque zahia m'a tuer la
sphère au monde et merci abou sofiane a
d'abord égalé combien ses côtés
[Applaudissements]